so you're at a floor store and you're
interested in buying some type of a
potted flower and you ask the florist
what type of flowers do you sell
and he says well we sell four types of
flowers we sell roses tulips sunflowers
and lilies and you say what type of pots
could i put them in and he says well you
could pick any flower and then you could
pick any of our three pots we have brown
pots we have yellow pots
and we have green pots
so the question that i ask to you is how
many types of i guess flour and pots put
together can you walk out of this floors
store with for example you could get a
rose and a brown pot you could get a
rose in a green pot or you could get a
yellow pot that has a sunflower in it or
a yellow pot that has a lily in it so
how many scenarios could you walk out of
that store with and like always i'll
encourage you to pause the video and try
to figure it out on your own
so let's think through it so i'll just
write the first letters just to just to
visualize or just have to write down
everything so you could have a
brown pot you could have
a
yellow pot or you could have a green pot
you definitely have to pick a pot so
you're gonna have one of those and then
for each of these three there's four
possible flowers you could have
you could have a rose with the brown pot
you could have a rose with the yellow
pot you could have a rose with the green
pot
you could have
you could have a tulip with a brown pot
a tulip with a yellow pot a tulip with a
green pot
you could have
a sunflower
with each
of the three pots and you could have or
you could have a lily with a brown pot a
lily with a yellow pot and a lily with a
green pot
so how many scenarios are we talking
about
well we had
we had three pots so we have three pots
right over here and we have four
possible flowers to put in the pots
and so we see that we have four possible
flowers for each of the three pots it's
going to be three times four
three times four possibilities or twelve
and you see them right over here this is
brown with red brown with or brown with
rose brown with tulip brown with
sunflower brown with lily yellow with
rose yellow with tulip yellow sunflower
yellow with lily so if we count these
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven
twelve twelve possible pot flower
scenarios to work out walk out of that
floor store with